[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay hi everyone thank you for coming
it's great to see some people here in
person um and i'm sure we have many
people uh with us virtually online via
zoom uh
just do a little plug next week we're
having a closed session that is an
alumni session uh with just our graduate
students and then the week after that we
will be having a session that is
exclusively virtual uh with nick
thurston from uk who will be speaking uh
the title of the stuff is document
practices the art of propagating access
uh so i
heard you all get excited about that
uh for today we have victoria kade
who teaches in the department of history
at northeastern university she's the
author of schools and screens of
watchful history from mit press 2021 as
well as numerous articles and chapters
on media technology and education she's
the co-author of life on display
revolutionizing u.s museums of science
and natural history from the university
of chicago press 2014
and her newest project explores the
history and politics of adolescent
privacy and i believe is under
consideration with mit press as of like
three days ago
so
yes
onward that's great so i bring you
victoria king all right
thank you so much for coordinating all
of the logistical details and thank you
guys
for showing up at 5pm on a thursday
um as heather mentioned i'm here today
to talk about this new book project or i
guess new book it's left the project
stage
schools and screens um
which is a history of efforts to reform
elementary and secondary education in
the u.s
through educational screen media so it's
funny that we're sitting right across
from justin wright's office because in
some ways i feel like i have done the
pre-history to a lot of what he talks
about and thinks about um
tonight i'm going to share some of the
research i did for this book
describe two case studies and conclude
with a reflection on how the book
relates to our current moment
so i started thinking about the history
of educational technology in u.s schools
a few years ago because the gap between
rhetoric and reality
seemed so enormous to me
as soon as common schools were
established in the united states in the
early 19th century people started
talking about ways to improve them
through technology and that kind of talk
only grew louder and more persistent
in the 20th century
and yet
despite all of this emphasis and effort
on
introducing new technologies to make
schools better it actually took a really
long time
for schools to embrace and integrate the
same screen media technologies that had
long permeated the rest of society so
the question of why were they so slow
that peaked my interest
and i was very lucky to start this
project just as a whole wave of
historians of media and technology were
beginning to wrestle
with different aspects of this history
i also benefited enormously from new
digital access to publications on
non-theatrical media and this is my
little plug for the media history
digital library if people haven't used
it yet you need to
so um the internet archive was the other
sort of wonderful
you know repository that you guys should
all check out particularly if you are
interested in the early history of like
personal computing
um so i started pawing through these
online resources but i also started
going into school board records and
education journals and all kinds of
archival materials from the early 1930s
when schools first started using film
on a more regular basis and then i have
gone all the way up through the early
2000s when nearly every school in the
united states was fully if you know
connected with some fragility um but
fully connected to the internet
i also read
as a starting point a lot of larry cuban
uh larry cuban is a terrific historian
of education
who wrote several books about classroom
technologies in the 1980s and the 1990s
um and he's really the guy who created
the master narrative
of the history of educational technology
and according to cuban um the story of
edtech is really cyclical efficiency
obsessed school administrators
foisted new technological tools on
teachers
um the technology was poorly designed
for existing classroom norms
teachers had have little incentive to
change those norms
teachers refuse to use the technology
the technology gets relegated to
storeroom shelves to die
rinse and repeat um and he makes this
argument that this happens with a whole
bunch of different kinds of machines and
in fact those of us who have either been
students or teachers may have seen that
cycle play out ourselves where the like
shiny new tool comes in and then it kind
of works but kind of doesn't and then
eventually it sort of goes away to some
library shelf and nobody ever sees it
again
so humans take is actually very
persuasive uh but his scholarly
interests were very much located in the
specifics of classroom teaching
and in school infrastructure he's a
historian of education he's really
interested in classroom culture
and when he was writing these books his
archival base was very limited
so i started thinking i was like you
know what
they've got to be
other ways to answer this question um of
why schools are so slow to adopt and
make effective use of screen media
um and i kept thinking well you know
expanding the frame of this research and
really digging into different sets of
archival materials might help shed me
light on this situation
and that is i'm hoping uh the
contribution that i'm making here um
what i found
was that there were four really pivotal
debates
over school stream media um and these
debates the tensions
that people got all heated up over um
often slowed schools embrace of these
tools i mean sometimes they actually
hasn't
school's integration of new screen media
technologies but either way it was these
four tensions that were pivotal in
shaping when and how and why
schools adopted screen media
technologies um
so here are the research findings and
i'm just going to go over them one by
one um
first
i would argue
that tensions of race and racism were
pivotal in shaping the history of
screenings in schools
people like to talk about technology as
race blind even though as scholars media
you know it's anything but um
and yet school screens were also
anything but progressive educational
reformers often looked to school screens
to help loosen the guardian knots of
racism and the multitude of ills that it
caused at the same time particularly in
the 50s and 60s
as well as later on
conservative white politicians and
school administrators also
made heavy use screen media technology
to justify and often reinforce
school segregation
despite reformers hopes that school
media technologies would help to
overcome
the quandary of race school screens
usually exacerbated race-based
educational inequities uh instead of
eliminating them i'm happy to talk a
little bit more deeply about that in the
q a
another theme that came up repeatedly
is that the history of school screens is
a history of the ongoing distrust
of educators
skepticism about educators abilities was
a major impetus for the introduction of
classroom tech
at the same time
when classroom technology
did make its way into american schools
americans often wondered whether
teachers were even competent competent
enough to handle
these tools so debates over school
screens
were usually debates over exactly what
teachers in schools could or should do
and also whether visual media
technologies could better accomplish
those tasks than actual human beings
a third finding
was that the history of school screens
is a history of the growing influence of
private funding
in public schools
from the 1930s through the 1960s the
rockefeller foundation the carnegie
foundation other major philanthropic
institutions
they initiated and they propped up
experiments in educational media
development and use and you'll certainly
see this in some of the case studies
that i offer later on
as a result these foundations wielded
outside influence over the politics and
practices surrounding school screenings
but it was really in the late 1970s
1980s and early 1990s that for-profit
corporations
became really powerful players
in promoting the school use of media
technology
and the lobbying donation and marketing
efforts of these corporations
truly expanded the use of streams in
schools but also helped to shape the way
that education was implemented in public
institutions in this country
a final discovery
was the way
and importance of tensions over the
appropriate role of screens in
citizenship education
schools have long been charged in the
united states with preparing youngsters
for engaged responsible participation
in an overlapping set of political
economic and social communities
but what exactly made students good
citizens and what exactly they required
from schools to get there
that was hardly a matter of consensus
screens just raised the temperature on
already heated discussions about
citizenship education especially given
americans long standing anxieties about
what screens did to kids
right people were worried back in the
1930s just as they are today
that screens are going to unleash
unpredictable desires or reduce
youngsters to unquestioning pacific
so experiments with and debates about
media technologies in schools
often revolved around how not only how
they would influence youth and there's a
lot of moral panic right that gets
associated with this
but it's really thinking about the ways
that they influence youth as part of the
broader quality thinking about how they
influence future citizens
um
so those were four
major tensions that came up in every
decade i studied over and over and over
again um
and those were
the as you can see i'll show you my
little
table of contents i end up organizing
the book kind of around
the debates chronologically
and you'll see those four tensions in
each chapter
but in addition to considering what
shaped the trajectory of screening media
technology in school i also began to
think about who
was engaging in these debates um
you know cuban had talked a lot about
school administrators those are you know
the anxious well-meaning villains um in
his narrative
but who were the reformers that were
like pushing screen media on schools did
teachers embrace them were parents
excited about them what about industry
writ large
um and what i found is that these
reformers could generally be associated
or sorted into three groups um
first you had advocates for
what i call civic spectatorship and i'm
going to talk about
that group today um they were one of the
earliest coalitions pushing screen media
into schools
progressive
politically liberal educators who
believed that schools have a
responsibility to promote civic
engagement and what we might now
describe as social justice
they saw schools as the engines for
reconstructing society in a better form
and from the 1930s on this group of
reformers argued that we need screens in
schools in order to give students the
opportunity to practice skills that will
help them navigate a civic realm
increasingly organized around screen
media
a second group pushing screens into
schools was made up of men and women but
mostly men
who believed that technology
provided and managed by experts was the
key to improving educational quality
these technocrats promised that schools
would modernize outdated educational
practice
scale high quality teaching and ease
long-standing educational inequities and
that they would do so at little to no
cost to taxpayers
so a lot of the rhetoric you hear coming
out of silicon valley now that is
pre-saged
by like our gentleman of the ford
foundation in the 1950s making grandiose
promises about educational television
and its powers
and the last set of cheerleaders um and
advocates for reforming schools through
screenings are people who are actually
in the business of producing and selling
media and technology to schools as well
as their allies in journalism and
government these are the people who
directly stand to profit from screens
whether it's financially or
professionally
and these three groups coexisted uh they
often overlapped each one was involved
in major experiments with school streams
over the course of the 20th century and
all of them seized moments of perceived
educational and social crisis which is
pretty easy because american schools if
you listen to the media are always in
crisis there is always a crisis going on
in education
um whether it's moral panic or economic
depression or domestic unrest or
international conflict or declining sat
scores like there's always a crisis
somewhere and always technology is going
to be the thing that saves us
um so the books chapters are as i
mentioned organized chronologically um
and in them i analyze
the most what i see as several is the
most notable experiments were that are
initiated by these reformers um and i
have to examine and analyze the debates
that result from their work
okay
so today what i want to do is i want to
go over two case studies um two
curriculum experiments that illustrate
some of the tensions that i just walked
you through
one is a success story
and it takes place in the 1930s and the
other is a cautionary tale
from this late 60s early 70s
but both focus on progressive reformers
progressive politically and progressive
pedagogically
interested in using screen media as a
way to promote
civic engagement um that is very much of
the moment
that they are operating in uh so my
first story takes place in the 1930s
as a very loose coalition of educators
and psychologists
and documentarians filmmakers uh who see
you know activism
through the realm of film um as their uh
so they begin to push schools to embrace
popular cinema
as a tool for citizenship training and
political engagement um
these reformers uh include film
appreciation advocates like edgar dale
uh william lewin educators uh like nyu
education professor alice
uh social activists like mary lucy who
basically got kicked off the march of
time because everybody fractured the
communist
um and they were all interested in
promoting a constellation
of visual analytical and social skills
that i described in the book as civic
spectatorship
now the term is a borrowed one um it was
coined by photography theorist ariela
azullay
to describe the way that spectatorship
of visual imagery can actually create
new social political and ethical
relationships among the viewers
and the view
and communication scholars robert
harriman and john lewis and katie's
elaborated on azole's ideas in the
american context suggesting that in the
united states in the 20th century united
states civic spectatorship is the
equivalent of literacy
when it comes to civic engagement it
contributes just as much
to shared political discourse
and to me the term very neatly sums up
what this kind of motley crew of
reformers hoped to accomplish
they believed that schools were in the
business
of preparing students for citizenship
in this wild wooly liberal
increasingly media saturated democracy
and so they argue that schools have a
responsibility to prepare students
for this new world um they had to help
students rehearse the skills that would
be necessary to parse through
visual propaganda
cinematic arguments um
the visual media that was beginning to
splash itself across every movie screen
every news stand you know every
billboard um
and they wanted them to not only have
these skills but to be able to apply
them
in a way that would help them engage
constructively with civic life
so these performers that's that's their
idea that's their ultimate ambition and
their focus but actually how that
translates into a k through 12 classroom
um that's a whole different deal um so
they consistently and somewhat radically
for the time
argue that the best way for schools to
accomplish this lofty goal
is to show popular films in class
often paired with news articles and
short social science readings and they
want kids to watch these films or shorts
based on these films
do these readings and then discuss the
sociological and psychological and
political dilemmas
that the films raise
it sounds very contemporary and
therefore very natural to us
but let me tell you during the 1930s
this is like
you know people were were a little
shocked with this idea um
and the films they suggested using were
wide-ranging uh they included dramas
like cavalcade or alice adams or
captain's courageous uh documentaries
like george island's spanish earth and
lots of newsreels uh like the march of
time
now reformers uh they were ambitious but
they were also extremely practical um
and many of them politically savvy and
they recognized just how large films
loomed in the lives of the students they
hoped to reach
especially during the depression right
and everybody's saving their nipples to
go to the movies during the depression
um and as one reformer alice caliga
wrote in 1936
quote the life of the american
adolescent is colored markedly by his
movie experiences
so schools have an obligation to
acknowledge the inherent power of the
photo play
and turn it to good use
so part of it is practical but part of
it is deeply psychological um
they believe they have this conviction
that films one two punch
of visual information and then emotion
prepares students to engage more openly
with the world that surrounds them
as edgar dale put it a book dealing with
the scientific mechanics of soil erosion
may leave us cold but a film like the
plow that broke the great plains stirs
us
so through the practice of civic
spectatorship of films
performers hoped students would begin to
deliberate empathetically and
collectively
about issues ranging from as dale put it
in 1938 quote the abolition of war
to a new point of view regarding crime
and punishment to the more satisfactory
distribution of wealth to a deeper
insight into the problems of democratic
government to an understanding of the
negro problem
end quote
educators were actually quite
enthusiastic about the idea of using
popular film in school teachers were
into this idea um they actually stood in
line there's this amazing petition
um that someone gathers in 1830 about
teachers who want to use popular film in
school
um and 100 100 1200 people signed their
name
to this one like local new haven
petition i mean teachers are all in
but district administrators originally
you know they initially resist on
financial events it's a depression they
can barely cover teachers salaries you
know much less electrify their world
schools and
deal with
you know rental fees for dramas and
documentaries and the projector
purchases
and other cultural obstacles too older
principals often forbade screening
modern motion pictures at school on
moral grounds
even when you know they pass must or
popular films tended to be too long
only peripherally relevant and quite
expensive uh film exhibitors had zero
interest in having films exhibited in
schools because they saw schools
very legitimately as a threat to their
business model
you could show movies at noon in the
cafeteria why would you
go to a film and actually pay money to
see it
so dale and kaliher and all of these
other reformers they're determined
though to push this notion of civic
spectatorship so they go hand in hand to
the rockefeller foundation and to a few
other foundations um and they begin to
negotiate with studios for the right
to exert and use films in the classroom
um they help districts develop
relationships with local theaters to
allow students to see second run films
in the middle of the day
they generate lots and lots of
curriculum
sometimes standalone units for like
history or english classes sometimes
whole courses that use film excerpts and
associated texts
to prompt student discussion of social
and political values and relationships
in modern american culture
uh and here actually there we go um so
scholars like craig crydell and eric
smuden and lisa ravine and katie dave
good
have also done a little bit of work
touching on these curriculum of various
places and you know we all agree it's
really obvious when you look at the
actual stuff i mean these curricula are
extraordinarily progressive they would
give a lot of republican members of
congress deep on
today
um
both pedagogically and politically um
you know they're talking about
uncomfortable civic issues uh economic
inequality racial discrimination
violence um
so for instance uh dale and we are both
developed curriculums that respectively
used the film fury uh 1936 spencer tracy
film featuring the near lynching of a
falsely accused prisoner and they use it
as an entree into the discussion
of the injustice of you know political
um and the justice system and the
epidemic of racial terror elections in
the american south
now these kinds of curricular units were
a big hit with urban educators whose
politics leaned left
and by the mid-1930s
some 10 000 classes and groups relied on
dale's guides
to promote civic spectatorship in and
out of school
the leaders human relations film series
curriculum or enjoyed similar popularity
by the end of the decade and was used in
several thousand schools those are just
a couple examples so this is you know
increasingly adopted
and yet the tensions that i mentioned at
the beginning of the talk
frequently slowed school's adoption and
use of such curricula
and film more generally um
industry advocates
and administrators uh objected to the
political undertones of these curricula
conservatives expressed reservation over
the rockefeller support for the
curriculum uh reservations that would
eventually take fuller form
in the investigations of the reese
committee uh launched in the late 1940s
and coming to big bear fruit in the
early
1950s there was widespread skepticism
about teachers abilities
uh to handle these films many school
wars looked askance
at the pedagogy that was promoted um on
which training and spectatorship
depended and proclaimed that students
were never going to be able to control
students or teachers were never going to
be able to control student discussion
about such fraught topics like oh it's
too risky it's too politically dangerous
what happens if the students get out of
control after they've been addled by
films
educators themselves were sometimes a
little bit wary as well they should have
been they knew that controversial films
or juvenile
sort of experiments and posing and
discussion could skin off course and
that held real peril for them
resulting in scolding
official inquiries even job loss
edward dale himself this leading
classroom film advocate you know he's a
professor at ohio state university he
got swept up in the wake of a 1939 red
hunting investigation by the trustees at
his own university
and he was required to testify as to
whether or not his approach to movie
viewing had resulted in student support
for strikers in columbus
um now we can also see the way that
contests over citizenship hampered the
adoption
of films in many schools
as global politics darkened at the end
of the 1930s films used in school rooms
assumed newly threatening civic
dimensions
radio was propagandist's preferred
instrument in the 1930s but europe's
rising dictators made extensive use of
film's political potential commissioning
hundreds of school films to prop up
their regimes and american parents
educators and politicians
were really worried that these films are
going to leak into american classrooms
one way or another
and that the practices of civic
spectatorship would just be no match
for the power of this insidious imagery
and such fears really tempered
enthusiasm for the kind of emotionally
driven discussion oriented pedagogy that
these reformers were promoting rather
than encourage open-ended discussion
declared maine high school principal
robert roach for white
educators should take a firm hand and
use school films to quote
inspire a democratic philosophy in the
personal creative american youth and
assist in the formation
of a patriotic spirit of national
community
in other words roshford white explained
they needed to provide students with a
queer and
explicit instruction in how to act think
and be
american
and to him open-ended discussion you
know that was not part of that um
once the war began explicit and
widespread desire to promote the war
effort
further dampened schools enthusiasm for
exploratory discussions of sometimes
ambiguous film messages
but once the war wound down
civic spectatorship really rebounded
um new film-based curriculum
drew very heavily on the work that had
been generated in the 30s by these media
reformers the practices and the
principles that have been espoused by
dale and lehrer and all of these other
kind of interwar education advocates
and both american educators and the
newly organized educational film
industry
adopted critical analysis and open-ended
group discussion as standard viewing
practice
in the 1940s because to many americans
cultivating these practices really stan
stood in stark contrast to the education
that had resulted in totalitarian
regimes the repression that they
associated with german and russian
schooling
so critical viewing and group
discussions seem to embody and reach
toward the kind of post-war democratic
ideals of free expression and tolerance
and rational compromise and
consensus-building
so the work of these inter-war reformers
that i write about actually offers
something as a prelude
to the cold war embrace of televised and
post-viewing discussions that anna
mccarthy writes about in the citizen
machine that's not a 50s phenomenon that
gets established earlier um indeed by
the end
of the 1940s
there is broad agreement among teachers
parents and policy makers
that civic spectatorship represents a
powerful social technology
capable of producing new and
constructive modes
of citizenship
so that's my success story um
yay progresses but uh educators
commitment to this kind of viewing
and pedagogical practice it really ebbs
and flows quite a bit over the next
several decades but it remains this sort
of undercurrent
in discussions in schools frames um
among champions of progressive
pedagogical ideals and really some you
know everybody just like on people's
radar
um and in the mid 1960s and early 1970s
this kind of pedagogy again fluoresces
it becomes enormously popular once again
as educators and activists
seek to meet the era's challenges by
teaching future citizens to analyze and
discuss new visual narratives critically
again in experimental multimedia
curricula that is sponsored by
foundations and universities um and it's
this that brings me to the second case
study
in this era um the mid 60s to early 70s
the single best known uh curricular
experiment was a curriculum called man a
course of study i don't know if you guys
have ever heard of that
it's not really like
you know painted your generation but i
remember it from when i was a kid
actually um and i'm old but i'm not that
um
so many courses study which was
nicknamed makos
was conceived in 1962 and launched in
1969 and mathos was a fifth grade social
studies curriculum
that was created by psychologists and
social scientists and educators over at
harvard university
and it was one of an alphabet soup of
curriculum reform projects that flooded
american schools after sputnik's 1957
launch americans got completely freaked
out that we were behind the russians and
we were like oh we have to reinvent
education
i know we'll launch a thousand different
curricular ships and this was one of
those ships
it was created with money from the
national science foundation and also a
series of private foundations
and
this curriculum was intended like the
others of this era to provide students
with disciplinary grounding and critical
thinking skills that would equip them
for more advanced study of subjects
considered essential to the united
states of war against the soviets
now like other federally sponsored
curriculum produced in this era make us
made extensive use of screen media by
the 1960s educators of all stripes from
you know the top dog superintendent to
the crustiest in class educator or
principal everybody was embracing screen
media it was new it was essential
it was how you proved you were sort of a
modern school um
and the designers of makos believe that
film would enable fifth graders to do
things that they otherwise might not be
capable of doing to grapple with
sophisticated evidence
through close observation and thoughtful
interpretation they might not have been
able to read or understand a really
difficult primary source document but
surely everybody can look
everybody can observe everybody could
analyze that's the thinking behind this
so they created a curriculum around 16
short documentaries that depicted
different animal and human communities
and the idea behind these documentaries
for students to act as sociobiologists
and anthropologists they watch footage
then they would ask questions and
develop and test hypotheses based on
this footage and then they would draw
conclusions based on their hypotheses
and a lot of back and forth discussion
and in this way declared one mapos
designer
students would learn what he called
quote a methodology thinking
at least thinking in a social science
way
but as historian of science erica milam
has pointed out the makos team believed
these films actually offered far more
than disciplinary training um the makers
team hoped that guided viewing and
discussion so sort of civic
spectatorship but 30 years later
of these films would shape students
self-concept and social character
and would ultimately alter their way of
being in the community and the quality
and the world
there was the visual side of it they
hoped that observing and analyzing
visual evidence would give students
practice
in the kind of critical measured
reasoning upon which they believed
democracy depended um
but they also again and here's that
emotional piece they also really hoped
that these big great american students
would identify deeply with the
indigenous subsistence cultures that
were depicted in these films and by
identifying with the kids they saw on
the screens who would radically
different lives of their own
that students would develop empathy and
appreciation for human commonalities
mako's team member and psychologist
richard jones neatly summed up the
team's ambitions quote if these
objectives can be realized then both the
future scholar and the future citizen
are served
think of the contemporary social ills
that could not exist
if a generation of americans could be
taught to identify in heart mind and
stomach
with the human species
cold war confrontations abroad
and civil rights battles at home
lends these endeavors a terrible urgency
raising students consciousness about
their shared humanity
seem to these curriculum designers the
only anecdote
to atomic peril and the only solution to
racial violence
swayed by marshall mcluhan's pretentious
intonations
make us planners believed that their
films would help students to stretch
their senses
and glimpse the global village of which
they were apart
so the ambitions of mako's designers
were very similar to those of our
progressive educational reformers in the
30s
but the films the actual material they
rely on to awaken this kind of feeling
and to help people practice the visual
and analytical skills radically
different
rather than rely on excerpts from
hollywood ethics or the march of time
make us course designers they're using
hardcore anthropological and biological
footage they rely on ethnologists to
create films of salmon and herringbones
and baboons
as well as the culture and lifestyle of
the sun people of the kalahari desert
and the netsillic uh people based in
nunavut canada
and the shorts that they produced looked
and sounded radically different from
most classroom films they were shot in
color for one thing
and they offered almost no on-screen
narration so if you go to youtube and
you look at like many mid-century films
from this period where they're telling
you like don't smoke fallout or whatever
you know it's like these centaurian
overtones the narrator is going on
that's not what's happening here you
hear waves you hear birds you hear winds
you hear people talking to each other in
languages that you don't understand
um and the reason for that is that
that mellifluous commentary the
curriculum designers they got for kids
to sleep they thought kids would just
check out and accept whatever the
narrator said right they wanted students
to really listen
and focus and engage and so students
would they would lean forward as they
tried to decipher what was happening on
these screens it was actually a very
elegant solution to anxieties about
passive spectatorship
these films challenged viewers with
little exposure to subsistence cultures
um
students watched children their own age
hunt birds by stoning them to death they
would watch
men harpooning seals in a fishing pole
uh they watch and this is something i
remember from fifth grade i don't know
if any of the other uh older people in
this room saw that but like there was a
scene where uh
kids ate the seal eye it was like a
delicacy um and and you know so you got
to watch little kids like delightedly
chomping away on this on this sea lion
it was and
you know
wrapping your head around that as a ten
year old is a big
act students have learned about netsil
and culture before they encountered
these films with readings and games and
projects so that they could
contextualize the act
but the images did retain their
emotional intensity
and this was quite intentional
curriculum designers
were committed to what they believed as
honest presentation of culture
and they hoped these scenes would plunge
students and teachers into deep
conversation
about the foundations of human culture
behavior and morality
such scenes wrote the curriculum lead
developmental psychologist jerome bruner
they forced students to quote rethink or
reorganize the moral judgments
and the role taking
in which they themselves were engaged
so when the course was finally launched
in 1969 educators and psychologists
failed it as a triumph i mean it's not
often that a fifth grade social science
curriculum course makes the new york
times but this one day it's like all
over the mainstream media as well as the
educational press
people praised its innovative design its
multimedia strategy its unflinching
examination of topics that
certainly have not been addressed in
elementary school social studies prior
to
um and course evaluation course
evaluators had special praise for the
film
reporting that they quote worked a magic
all their own and quote drew students
into a shared experience with the people
shown
but as the course began to filter into
american schools critics also emerged
evangelicals
john bercher social conservatives
began to stage aggressive protests
against this curriculum at school board
and community meetings so
all of the hubbub over crt right now you
can think about that but you know
45 years earlier um
protesters regularly cited the films
as the course's single most
objectionable element
like i said makos designers had seen
these films as like honest biological
and cultural records that would prompt
critical thinking and thoughtful
discussion
conservative protesters on the other
hand denounced these films
as the forms of x-rated decadence that
would lead to psychological damage and
classroom and anarchy
um a mounting scene in one of the
herringbone films provoked almost a riot
at a community meeting is set in the
suburb west of denver
uh because parents
believed that showing sexual behavior
even if that behavior
were occurring
in the bird world
um ran close to sodomy and was downright
immoral
um
much of the criticism centered on
students physical and psychic reaction
to the film's more intense scenes which
critics described as nauseating
violating and shocking
is there any gain in giving young
children pictures in which they see
animals
being skinned alive
asked one opponent um protesters
definitely did not trust teachers to
guide students through this content
conservatives argued that the average
teacher would either bundle discussion
of children's reactions or
refuse to address the reactions
altogether
leaving students unclear about what to
think and heavily traumatized to boot
critics also opposed the film's quiet
message of cultural relativism and what
they called one worldism
as california-based makos critic john
steinbacher called it
by presenting excellent culture in
straightforward terms
the film suggested that the behaviors
that deviated from middle class american
christian norms were
possible
tolerable
and sometimes even admirable
and to conservatives confronting the
chaotic culture of the early 1970s
presenting these alternatives as valid
seemed treacherous uh unpatriotic even
they rejected the ecstatic humanist
vision
that makos designers had articulated and
that they had hoped this media would
help students realize
and they scorned the ideologies and
skills that made those films were
intended to promote
this was not the kind of spectatorship
that classrooms should engender
these opponents argued and this was not
the kind of citizenship
that schools should seek to inculcate
so debate over the curriculum became so
heated and again let me remind you this
is a fifth grade social studies
curriculum right it becomes so heated
that this guy
uh republican congressman john conlon
took the matter to the floor of the u.s
house of representatives where he
demanded that congress
banned the curriculum from american
schools
according to conlan makos and its films
functioned as quote cultural shock
techniques
and that they were designed to persuade
children to reject the values beliefs
religions and national loyalties
of their parents and american society
the films he argued had no place in the
public schools of
america so the vociferous reaction to
this course permanently crippled not
only makos's sales but also federal
funding for classroom media production
for several years thereafter um after
conlon brought the attention or this
curriculum to congress's intention uh
nsf director national science foundation
director guy stever
he backed off i mean he promised to
withhold funds from any pre-college
science course curriculum development or
implementation until a special panel
could review all nsf efforts and what
this meant in practice
was that these kinds of bold multimedia
experiments
simply became unaffordable um
private publishers had zero interest in
sinking the money and to create
elaborate films and multimedia
um at least until you know gaming came
about um and you know computer software
made it profitable again
um and without federal funds to prop up
this kind of sophisticated multimedia
curriculum development it simply fell
into disuse
so what can we take away
from these two very different moments in
the history of school strengths
well in both instances um the
curriculums were animated by educators
concerned about racism in the 1930s
about anxieties over lynching
in the 1960s
an effort to sort of support civil
rights in an arms-length way um an
effort to really get students to think
of themselves as members of a larger
human community
and they motivated the use of screen
media in particular
educators believed that the emotional
and experiential elements of visual
screen media would enable students to
tap into a kind of immediate empathy
that other forms of media simply would
not um elicit and as a result i hoped
that this kind of film
or film strips or other kinds of visual
media would really help a generation of
students relate to one another in new
ways
in both instances the question of who
was funding school streams was a major
point
of concern and
retention as i mentioned the production
and purchase of high quality stream
media and technology often required
resources
far beyond what an individual district
could muster
and so experiments with school screens
uh both getting them into the schools
and then generating the curriculum that
was used this really required either
philanthropic or federal funding
but the american education system is
intensely
local and over the course of the 20th
century communities communities
vacillated between a commitment to run
local schools without intervention from
outsiders
and a desire to be modern and to adopt
media products technologies and
curricula
that was produced and sponsored by say
the rockefeller foundation or the
national science foundation
um often in conjunction with broader
industry
but event screens became political
writing rights um and so questions over
the appropriate role of both
philanthropy and government
in media production that just amplified
these controversies
in both of these case studies reformers
attempted to use film and classrooms to
teach students
new ways of relieving relating to screen
media for the purposes of citizenship uh
to help them cultivate both the skills
and the selves
that they thought was important uh for
american citizenship in an age of
screens
but again in both eras almost
immediately questions arose as to what
kind of skills and selves
schools should actually be trying to
construct and whether or not educational
media that was being used for that
purpose could actually accomplish it
as the anxious debates over these two
sets of very different classroom films
make clear
pictorial screen media pressed hard
on the tenuous boundaries between
emotion and reason
body and mind
self and society
blurring these boundaries within the
carefully guarded confines of the
classroom
unnerved parents
administrators and even educators and as
a result
in the 1930s educators
even those who embraced the idea of
using popular films in their classrooms
often backed away from films that had
ambiguity
about where national loyalties lay in
the instance of makos the perception
that these films were blurring these
same boundaries resulted in a political
firestorm that was too hot for any
curriculum to survive
the history of school screens is
ultimately a history of changing ideas
about screen media's impact on students
it's a history of evolving arguments
about who should control classrooms
and most of all the eight decades
struggle to determine the proper
relationship between schools and screens
is a history of ongoing disagreement
about schools purpose
in u.s society
now as they've done for nearly a century
educators today still debate
how and if schools can use screens to
minimize rather than reinforce existing
inequities
they ask themselves to what extent
disrespect for teachers is driving or
shaping future school plans or screens
and whether or not money invested in
technology might be better spent
elsewhere um like on the teaching staff
and everybody still wants to know how
screens can you know be used to promote
posix positive civic engagement and how
to prepare students for citizenship
in an even more complex digital age
preparing students for citizenship in a
media mad media-made democracy remains
an urgent task today
in an era of media convergence this is
enormously challenging and you know that
yourselves right educators they're
struggling with data breaches and
questions of digital surveillance
pundits and parents argue about schools
ethical and legal responsibilities um
when it comes to things like racist
memes or screen addiction or cyber
bullying
troubling aspects of school life in the
digital age
and the problem of how to confront
misinformation uh sober's even the most
optimistic educator
in 2016 for instance the stanford
history education group released a
report
announcing that young people's ability
to reason about the information on the
computer screen can be summarized in one
word
believe
without more attention to civic
reasoning skills predicted american
society's shift to screens
would deeply damage democracy
and this report was completed two months
before trump was elected
so in this contemporary moment of
profound fragmentation much of it taking
place over media
um
part of me wonders whether we should be
going the same route uh encouraging the
same kinds of classroom pedagogy that
our depression era advocates
spectatorship and the mapos folks
encourage
slow down
carefully or analyze and discuss all
manner of media in small diverse groups
with an eye towards considering
how to use this media for productive
civic ends
as we all know there are considerable
risks to doing this it requires trust in
educators
skill and guiding discussions um
you know and discussion can seem real
challenging right now perilous even um
and yet classroom screens still
guarantee a physical place
in which people of varying backgrounds
can gather to practice civic behavior
and discussion
in a country that is badly in need of
common ground
so that's my talk
um
[Applause]
thank you so much um i'm wondering if i
can keep this up for two questions go
for it um
one is wow like a lot of things you've
said really resonated with a lot of
material we've been reading in our
graduate class right 801 media
transition um
[Music]
1933 and i was struck by fury i believe
it was from 36.
and i was wondering if the um first case
study was specifically of a post pain
fund studies moment where there's a kind
of like oh we've seen how movies are bad
and how these studies were popularizing
our moving children as if they
showed
i wonder if that discourse is sort of
happening or that dialogue and also to
what extent the film industry is like on
board with this as like great pr for
them right as opposed to some of the
earlier publicity before the production
code administration stuff in 1934 which
we also talked about um so that's my
first question and my second question is
just about sort of
cost efficiency and economic issues with
uh the the makeovers project
um i'd like to know if uh
you know if these films were rented for
example as opposed to being purchased
um
and
it seems like there's a way
this is a little equal pair but i'm
obsessed with film strips okay and one
of them there are a lot of film strips
in that okay that's probably tons
of you can talk about this oh my god
but it's like with film strips once you
buy them
um and so they're not they're i don't
know if everyone knows these but they go
through a projector one frame at a time
and there's a cassette or a photograph
album to go with it that plays along
with audio right and once you buy it as
a teacher in a public school classroom
you can just put it in the closet and
whip it out whenever you want and the
school board doesn't have to keep track
of it and the way they would like rental
materials or you know getting a new
curriculum every year and so it means
that you can have your say creationist
film strip in the closet or
[Laughter]
you have initial controversial perhaps
and then you don't because it just sort
of goes subterranean so i'm wondering
like are they sustaining controversy
because they keep
you know publicizing it so that more
people buy it and or subscribe or what
you know whatever so two sort of very
different questions
so let's start with the first question
and it's a terrific question because
you're right
the 1930s is this like watershed moment
where people i mean because the movies
are becoming so enormously popular and
such a critical sort of economic engine
they're transforming you know education
in american life and people just
wondering
what does that what does this all mean
um you know and particularly with pain
what does this mean for our kids ever
dale actually is one of the authors on
the painful studies and he
his little like very accessible reader's
guide like how to watch the movies um
you know this helps to kick off the film
appreciation movement which is an effort
to use movies sort of analyze them again
for constructive purposes and a lot of
the people that i was talking about were
very much affiliated with this film
appreciation
moment um
now film appreciation had it was like a
big spectrum some people were like we're
just going to watch movies of charles
dickens and use this as a way to explore
the novel um and some people were a
little bit more politically radical like
dale himself who starts out
a little bit more conservative but by
the end of the 30s he's like burn it all
down
you know he's he is much more
committed to the idea
of using films to engage students
in what um
sometimes in the educational world gets
called social social reconstruction so
the idea that schools are going to
reconstruct society in a better image of
itself
um
and he
is often involved in meaningful debate
um and pressure on hollywood there's a
famous debate he gets into with martin
quigley who is the editor of uh
[Music]
yeah and i actually almost threw um one
of the headlines up where it's like
they're having this debate and actually
maybe i can even i think i might have
included
one
yes
now come educators with plea for films
of social insight
so in some ways industry is embracing
this when it is convenient for them like
they love themselves from alex
because they see her as acceptable she
depersonalizes and depoliticizes a lot
of this she's really interested
in the psychological angle
and the idea of introducing students to
film in order to help them
psychologically adjust to the challenges
of modernity she's got this very
forward-thinking way
of helping students tangle with their
own identities and think about their own
position in society and how that could
be changed over time
but other reformers um dale among them
married lucy who edits and creates a
whole film curriculum that goes with the
march of time
um which is
crazy town radical i mean like it's it's
really funny to hire william lewin at
the march of time to create one health
curriculum and then they hire mary losi
and if you read them in context it's
they don't match um politically or
pedagogically but you know those folks
are pushing industry
to create classroom films and to create
films
that are
what one might think of as more socially
engaged to promote and push issues of
what we would now call social justice
and what they then called social insight
so
industry saw
this kind of group of reformers in a
couple of different ways in some ways
they were like
you annoying socratic horse fly get out
of here stop talking at us we're gonna
make the films we want to make
you know our profit is is ultimately
productive for america
what's going in the classroom is not our
problem
on the other hand they were delighted
to you know seize credit
when they saw a film-based curriculum as
fundamentally unobjectionable and when
it was getting praised in the press so
again let me go up here so this is
actually part of the mgm house
publications like every year mgm would
put out a yearbook
of what it had done for the community
and this was featured large um you know
in in terms of the shorts that it had
created
you know one of one of the things that
it did was like boast of all of the
shorts that it's provided to the leader
and the rockefeller foundation for the
purposes of educating future citizens so
industry is really playing both sides um
so that is question one
question two um thinking about the
economics of makers
so maybe this is a really funny thing um
and this is what happens when you get a
whole bunch of experts in a room who are
not talking to anyone else
because as
these harvard guys um who are you again
brilliant social scientists and
psychologists and educators they're
starting to workshop the film in schools
actually in newton and cambridge and
brookline
throughout the 60s
and every time they go in
the teachers you know these nice like
fifth grade teaching ladies are like
guys this is great but you really need
to worry about two things this seems
really complicated and expensive number
one and number two
we this might raise some eyebrows among
parents we're not really sure how we're
going to explain it
and
you know the people who are designing
the curriculum like no no it's going to
be great there's not going to be any
issues
um and of course
both things explode simultaneously um
and one big issue is cause when it comes
when they finish the curriculum
it is the most expensive most
complicated social studies curriculum
ever designed because when i say it's
multimedia i mean like truly multimedia
there are games there's like a life-size
seal puzzle
there are you know like there are there
are 54 booklets that go along with this
each kid has you know seven or eight
booklets the teacher material alone
requires separate training films plus
the curriculum development team wants in
order because they know this is gonna be
hard they know the films are weird and
disturbing and ambiguous
and so they want to make sure that
teachers are going to be trained
to use them properly so they don't try
to require like 40 hours of teacher
training
in order to make this happen um they
can't find a publisher nobody's gonna
touch this thing with a 10-foot pole
because
what does fifth grade traditionally
teach in the united states at this time
that's american is true
so you're really gonna oust american
history for like weird films about the
nuts look and like
baboons you know
like
people don't know what to make
so they end up going
at the end of the day with this tiny
little
fledgling uh
kind of curriculum development shop
educational development publishers um
and they simply don't have enough money
to sink into it so this is sort of um
it reminds me of one of these films that
is you know gets glowing reviews and
nobody actually goes to see um makos
creates this enormous splash um and it
lingers for a long time in american
schools because it really is an amazing
curriculum but it's incredibly expensive
um and so most of the users of it quite
honestly are private schools um
where you have you know enough
investment and materials to get it or
liberal-leaning public school districts
went in well-heeled suburbs
and then there's also some penetration
into inner city
in terms of um sort of
gifts or grants in order to purchase
this very forward thinking curriculum
um
in terms of the actual films themselves
they were largely purchased and that
becomes again a really big issue um at
this time it was possible to rent them
but because the curriculum was so
expensive it was limited
to certain communities um and that's
another sort of interesting thing about
the activist backlash because in a lot
of the schools
the activists were not actually people
with children
in the schools themselves they were
coming from the outside as part of sort
of more generalized frustration about
the direction american education was
going because remember this is the same
era where
busing is taking place so all of a
sudden there's a lot of discussion about
who schools are for and what schools are
for
there's this is the same time that uh
we're starting to have new conversations
about sex ed curricula entering schools
we're starting to have new conversations
about bilingualism
in schools and the supreme court has
just banned prayer
in schools no longer is there like a ten
commandments left on the wall and every
kid like taking a minute to pray after
saying the pledge of allegiance so this
is a time of enormous sort of moral and
ethical turmoil in terms of thinking
through schools and a lot of times these
activists kind of jump on the train of
objecting to makers because they see it
as part of a larger declension
in american education that there's
something about the mako's films that
they really object to um
and it's interesting that you say this
because
it's really descriptions of the films
that they object to because they don't
actually watch the film they can't
actually see
the film so one exception to that is in
washington dc
where there is a reporter who wants to
make a name for herself so she creates a
kind of like a two-piece show
about how like
what kid's watching in schools and she
manages to get shorts
from the actual curriculum producers
itself no it's interesting because a lot
of the shorts she ends up showing
um as clips in this news story are
actually shorts that ended up getting
cut so for instance they had this whole
unit on the sun of people of the
kalahari that they end up getting cut
that they end up cutting because they're
like whoa it's 1969 do we really want to
have a short
of black men who are you know
effectively undressed and hunting with
spears
you know
in like going out into american schools
in 1969 we think this is a terrible idea
like we don't want to perpetuate
negative stereotypes we think this is
going to be way too hot to handle
so they kill people
um
and yet it winds up in the news report
as something that is seen so so visual
media provides a particularly explosive
and yet weirdly under
like
it has all the power of gossip um but no
very few adults who are activists have
actually seen the movies in russia
[Music]
other questions
yeah
go ahead
okay well i have two questions um one is
very quick is it possible to see the mgm
shorts and the makos films and if so
where but i also wondering if you think
that these kinds of practices these
kinds of curricula
um
fluoresce uh as you would say during
moments of kind of pronounced media
transition and social transformation you
know this kind of 1930 moment and this
late 1960s moment and um if so you know
is that something that could be kind of
plotted i that's a really interesting
question and i would say you know yes
perhaps even as a counter model to the
cyclical story exactly i mean as a short
answer yes i think it's much easier to
embrace this kind of multimedia
curricula at moments where progressive
pedagogy resurfaces and becomes
enormously popular and a lot of times
that is
that takes place in times of
deep social change um i think when you
see
curriculum and pedagogy particularly
become more conservative and ratchet
back are moments of kind of unified fear
um you see that in the 50s for instance
where there's sort of a reaction against
progressive pedagogy
it's associated with communism it's you
know people get very nervous and we just
we need to have
more um
top-down
content-oriented
uh
teaching in order to compete
um and film is a tricky medium in the
classroom in certain ways because it is
rich with information and in some ways
it delivers information very efficiently
but it's very hard
to assess um
and
often students don't glean as much from
a film content-wise as they do from a
textbook page
and so in moments where there's a lot of
emphasis
on quantitative assessment um so here
i'm thinking about the standardized
testing regimes
of you know the 21st century which you
guys all grew up in and experienced and
everybody like went through that um if
you're watching movies and interpreting
them and talking like how do you
evaluate that like kind of it becomes a
much trickier proposition so at times
when america is feeling particularly
anxious whether it's about its own
participation in a global economy
whether it is about um
you know some kind of international
threat or internal or domestic threat
like sometimes people ratchet back
and it's not that they run away from
screens but they use screens in a very
different way the kind of
there's a lot less dis there's a lot
less comfort with the ambivalence
that visual images like the ones i show
brought um and i don't remember the
first part of your question so just
where can we can we see these films yeah
you can see them absolutely they're you
know they're sort of around on youtube a
lot of libraries still have makeup
stones
that you can see and then there are some
odd collectors websites like there's
there's like nicos online um where you
can watch some of the movies um and
that's fun and weird um
yeah and then the mgm shorts i they're a
little harder to track down um i believe
the rockefeller foundation has most of
the materials but the guy to talk to
would be craig crowdell who's at the
university of south carolina and he runs
their educational film kind of archive
but he is really the specialist on the
human relations film series so if
anybody
has a collection of those shorts he does
let's do one stupid question and i saw
what we have on
apologies for kind of half formulating
questions
no need to apologize
yeah of ariella absolutely and her ideas
about this civil contract and
photography civic spectatorship is that
she really differentiates between um
kind of the the subjects of the
photographs those who are just possessed
marginalized on the periphery right and
then basically kind of those of us in
the west
who um and my understanding is that
she's actually quite against this kind
of
formulation that photography can be used
to stir empathy this kind of western
humanist um
like argument for the power of
photography but that instead you know it
should um
make clear to us the ways that we are
complicit in on perpetuating dominant
structures so i guess i'm curious like
you mentioned really briefly the makers
curriculum was sometimes donated to any
schools
um just kind of
like the particulars of where this is
being utilized whether it's being
utilized differently perhaps and
predominantly
black you know you know like what was
going on and how was it being used how
were teachers being trained
um because it does
seem that the kind of empathy
model is quite not yeah not very much
what she's talking about and it's
interesting and i'm really glad you
bring that up because there is a big
range and it's something these reformers
in the 60s and then in the 30s were
highly conscious of
um and i'll give you an example of the
mapus reformers themselves so they were
very worried that
the empathy that would be evoked
would be kind of weirdly colonized and
they spent a lot of time they're like oh
my god you know we had one workshop and
the teacher was like let's send them
care packages i'm like we have to figure
out how to like present this in a way
that they don't feel sorry for you that
they're seeing
how do you
encourage a kind of cultural
cultural relativism but also like
engagement on the terms of the people
involved and they actually end up making
a short um
so the nets like people who are filmed
for
this
series
they are reenacting to like complicated
and get really
many of the traditions
of
their but this is common in documentary
yes
and this is something that comes up also
in the documentaries in the 30s that get
used in a lot of these classrooms um and
you can see it like in one um a kid's
like wearing modern underwear there's
like a yellow band-aid and like one
scene and the fifth graders are like oh
oh i see you know they're like noticing
everything
so the makos designers realize that
they've got
first of all they don't want to play
into exactly what you're talking about
um so they actually make a film about
making uh the making of kind of film um
the vanessa like here today and then the
next lick
in the past um and one of the other sort
of interesting elements there is the
next look end up
loving and being extraordinarily
grateful for the naked films because
they see them as part of the legacy and
embrace of
their own
tradition they see this as an act of
preservation of their old culture rather
than an exploitative gesture um so there
end up being a series of films
about not just the making of the film
but the use of the film and how to
navigate
these complicated discussions about
race anthropology
um and i guess even maybe othering is i
mean that's not the word that's not the
language they use in the 60s um and part
of the teacher training
is
showing these films
to and and anticipating
student comments and students tendencies
to pity
um or distance uh
the subjects on screen rather than
engaging with them on their own how do
teachers how should teachers handle it
and they show a range of possible
questions that students might ask in a
range of possible responses
um there's also
i mean anthropologists themselves
are generating these films and they too
have a lot of takes on how
the films get edited in order to ensure
that they are as respectful as possible
to
the people and and sort of capture the
proper vision of the people who are
you wouldn't really say starring that
the people who are whose lives are being
represented so these are issues that
people have in mind and they are
wrangling with them in real time um
they're very explicit about that in
the 60s and 70s in part because i mean
it's a moment in anthropology where
people are wrestling with that in new
ways um in the 30s there's sort of a
wider range um in part because
many of the films they're using are not
documentaries um you know they're
they're fictional films and so the kind
of empathy that is being unleashed is
slightly different than what as aware is
talking about
um but the documentaries that they're
talking about and that they're making
use of
um they are trying to
again engineer not not the distance that
comes with pity but more um
an equivalency and a sort of sense of
engaged
connection um to reorient
that relationship between subject and
other so that it is i mean again it's
more of a mutual contract i guess
yeah so does that answer your question
from justin so he actually he noticed
that we're running a shirt on time so he
said
another student asked questions
[Music]
replacing teachers uh sort of like
robotic teaching and if this is that
it's totally ours in utopia right
um i i know at some point this kind of
coincided taking the 80s with ideas like
you probably management to see public
servants as us providing a service
that's
whatever
see the very last bit again so i'm
interested in this if screens can
operate in some way of this discourse as
homogenized saying kind of public goes
in one way um so
i mean in terms of screens replacing
teachers this has long been
an undercurrent of discussion um and it
is not in the best interest of any
producer of media to be like yeah we're
putting people out of business to
definitely buy our wares
um so usually they are sort of putting a
foot in both camps like oh it will
enhance it will complement under those
circumstances will it replace teachers
and yet if you actually read margin
notes marginalia of letters or memos
if you um you know over if you read
through the transcripts of these
conversations where teachers are not
present um that is very much
part of the mix
there's a lot of disregard and
disrespect for what teachers do
particularly particularly among
technocrats
who will often say you know the media is
going to do an infinitely better job
you know or the programmers will do a
far better job of handling these issues
whether it's content advance or skills
practice
um than teachers will so why are we
wasting money on these human beings
um so you see that
prominently in the 1950s with
educational television where people
especially in the ford foundation which
is what i talk about in the book
they start touting this idea of why why
would we rely on mrs hunford angle to
teach fourth grade music when we could
get like the best of the best let's get
leonard bernstein to teach the fourth
grade
um
sounds like master class it totally
absolutely like that um
but you know as anybody who had a fourth
grader last year
during covent knows um sometimes you
don't want leonard bernstein on the
screen sometimes you want mrs humperdink
with like symbols and the you know the
orf instruments um there's a difference
in terms of
live classroom communication um
it's really easy to say that there isn't
um
but i think that's where educators
you know emphasize it over and over
again and it's interesting because the
development and the age groups um the
conversation changes with age groups
people get more excited about the
possibilities of screens replacing
actual teachers in the later stages
of education i mean nobody's suggesting
that that is a good idea in kindergarten
like everybody's like us charlie but um
you know it's something that gets
floated over and over again
well you know a school might not have
the the resource is to hire a mandarin
teacher or like an advanced calculus
teacher so why wouldn't we
use technology as a replacement um
and you know within the like i am i'm
not a sort of contemporary ed tech
person here i feel like i should defer
to justin wright who is apparently in
the audience um
you know there's a lot of discussion
about whether or not media
can replace
or can sort of supplement um but
you know even though
every single media producer will
absolutely disavow replacement
um in public if you go into the archives
in private at least historically there
is far more discussion
about the possibility
of
techno-utopian replacement
than you anticipate that you will find
um
thank you
well i guess we have run up against time
so we will stop here thank you again uh
for the wonderful talk and a great
discussion thank you to everyone
[Applause]